when I was running my agency I started
watching Mad Men and cuz that's all
about advertising agencies of the' 60s
50s 60s um and there's one scene in it
where one of the partners at their um
what's it called Sterling Cooper Draper
price or just Sterling Cooper to start
with and then um so there's one scene
where one of the partners is in his
office and someone marches up the hall
towards him and says oh no we've lost
caby like they they've lost this m
client and it's such a big deal and he
goes are you going to walk up the hall
every time we lose a client like you'll
wear the carpet out like it's not that
much of a big deal and just putting
those things into perspective and being
able to constantly reframe is like what
entrepreneurship is all about and then
you find that less bothers
you